نرحب
بالسفير الفلسطيني، فالشعب الفلسطيني لديه
الحق في
وطنه بعد أن عانى أجيالاً من
القمع والاحتلال
والانتهاكات الفظيعة لحقوق الإنسان التي
يجب أن تهز الإنسانية الليلة الجحيم. تهطل الأمطار
على غزة، غزة، ساحة
الأطفال العظيمة، تحصد حياة طفل كل 10
دقائق إسرائيل.  يدعي أنه يتصرف
دفاعًا عن النفس من خلال قصف المدنيين،
والعقاب الجماعي، وذبح
الآلاف من الأطفال ليس
دفاعًا، وهذه ليست
ردودًا مبررة على الهجوم المروع الذي شنته
حماس في السابع من أكتوبر، حيث
يرى العالم تصرفات إسرائيل على أنها
جرائم حرب وحشية وجبانة وبغيضة.  هذه لحظة حساب
لقادة العالم بالنسبة للاتحاد الأوروبي، وهي
اختبار للالتزام بالديمقراطية والسلام وحقوق الإنسان،
ونسأل أين حماية
القانون الدولي لكل طفل
يُقتل في غزة ولكل أم في غزة
تحمل جثة طفلها القتيل الباردة
إسرائيل؟  لا يمكن السماح بارتكاب
فظائع مع
الإفلات من العقاب، تقول الحكومة إن
أفعال إسرائيل لا يمكن أن تكون دون
عواقب، وأنا
أوافق على ذلك، ولهذا السبب يجب على الحكومة الأيرلندية أن
تأخذ زمام المبادرة وتحيل إسرائيل إلى
المحكمة الجنائية الدولية
وترسل السفير الإسرائيلي إلى
وطنه [تصفيق]